yeah we hung out and have fun but did I
want to be in a long-distance
relationship with you afterwards
no and that should be okay with you I
try to call him and he refused to talk
to me on the phone do you have any
breakup text actually I don't
I do we did it I was kind of like 20/20
vision I get rid of my demons breakup
text I deleted them all I until he did
them I prefer to do that stuff in person
or at least on a FaceTime and not
through text oh I have the text let's do
it
that was fun but maybe I should let
you focus on school she said okay haha I
said I mean if you really need time I
don't want you getting bored of me
faster she said I get bored faster oh no
she said oMG but okay if you say so
I'm like okay and then we ended it there
okay and then I just feel better it was
the most invested I had ever been in the
relationship we had said I love you to
each other already and then she texted
me at breaking up with me if I'm being
totally honest I've had a lot of time to
think about everything and I really only
have time to focus on school I don't
think our personalities click super
great at this time in my life even
though you're absolutely wonderful I
feel like my only compatible personality
right now for me is Joss for a context
justice for Kat I'm sorry for the
potential stress and frustration I've
caused you I hope you can forgive me Sam
I'm super upset at life right now but I
understand and respect your priorities
and why you're doing this kind of wish
we could talk about this in person at
some point I have some questions if
that's okay hope you're doing okay send
us a kissy kiss then we had exchanges
for maybe a month where I kept being
like okay so like can we meet and she
would be like yeah sure this week and
then she'd be like actually I'm busy
maybe next week and I was really
disappointed because I thought you know
you at least owe me like an apology or
something in person and I thought you
know what we had was a little more real
than that yeah so if gonna hit the fan
and her car got towed and she needed six
hundred bucks I'll enter the
$600 and then on June 16th 2018 I said
good morning at 8:05 no response hey
baby
at 1:43 no response 11:30 p.m. I said
good night event from the 20th the
exchanges of this hey hey
hey you smiley face because I'm cool
listen I'll pay you back as soon as I
can but I can't be in a relationship
with you it wastes too hard on my
conscious that I'm not a good partner
I'm sorry to do this new text I don't
have that energy for more right now
you're free be happy with someone normal
a couple months later I didn't get a
text from her but I got a message from
her email to my phone and it's her it's
like hey Eric I hope you're doing well
also just let you know I should be able
to pay back next month
sorry about the forever wait and I've
never I have I've still never seen the
money she liked to leave me off all
social media and that was like two years
ago three years ago okay look I saw your
phone while waiting for you and I saw
her as your screensaver I don't know
what's going on anymore but I think I
have a good idea at this point
and of course what are you talking about
and I just saw him I want to know why
she's your screensaver and there's a 30
minute blank no response but he leaves
me on red so I'm like okay I know he's
thinking of a lie I know he's thinking
of something to tell me and this is what
he comes up with it's an app I found
that changed his screensavers like a
slideshow I have so many pictures I
couldn't choose one come on you know I
wouldn't do like that you know I'm like
okay I knew in that moment all the red
flags were in fact red flags and this
relationship needed to be done he kind
of attacks me and he's like okay but
believe what she want so I said in like
three question marks like whoa then he
ends the conversation and he goes like I
said believe what you want
it's an app and sorry she was the screen
saver when you looked but you know I
love you and wouldn't do you like that
and it hurts to think that you think
it's like that I'll talk to you later
and he put a period at the end so he was
being very stern because that's not how
he talks or types so I knew that he
blames it on me for believing
what was the truth so that's kind of how
it went
he's still with the girl he reaches out
to me sometimes he stalks my Instagram
profile so I said there's something I've
been wanting to tell you but it's
something that should be said in person
are you doing anything on Saturday and
then I said which or would you rather
not see me he said I really don't want
to see you I'm sorry I said understand
it's a lot and he said just tell me
or don't tell me at all and I said okay
let me type it up he's it okay don't
tell me at all goodbye Anna and I said
it's something I need to say but I'm
gonna tell you just give me a few
minutes and he said dude really Anna
this is ridiculous and I'm like trying
to type it up but I kind of learned like
it just has to be short and sweet it
can't be me saying like I'm in pain or
you know I'm going through this so I
said long story short since you don't
want the full story is um I was having a
miscarriage a week we broke up I didn't
know until last Friday and he said okay
Anna I'm really sorry about that
I said I'm probably I probably should
have kept that to myself he said no it's
okay I'm gonna go to sleep though they
said that hurts because it's like I
didn't even know that I was pregnant
beforehand it was it was hard and so I
wanted to reach out to him I don't know
I don't know I thought he would care and
I don't know why I wanted him to care
too because obviously like we weren't no
matter what we weren't gonna be together
I was just like going through something
like that really changes your your head
and so it's hard to move on when there's
that constant reminder of what could
have been and what you know I went
through and so I'm feeling hopeful but
it's just
it's hard sometimes a big thank you to -
Lana for supporting this episode for
making our content possible for those of
you who don't know - Lane is awesome it
securely generates and stores all of
your password information across every
device so you never have to click lost
password again it can start your
passport info your Wi-Fi info your
banking info and even auto fills your
credit cards so you never have to go
searching through your wallet which is
super great for travel yeah and speaking
of trouble there's also BPM so you won't
be tracked and you can access content
while browsing the Internet in other
countries so for all you good humans out
there make sure you go to - Lang com / -
bleah
forget - lame free on your first device
and make sure you use the code Jubilee
when you're ready to upgrade to premium
and get 10% off make sure to LIKE
comment subscribe and I'll see you next
time